[Music]  i went around and  met with all the other restaurants that  are in the neighborhood we're all part  of the downtown community  and i said let's all get together and  try and work together so we can  bring more people downtown from locals  from summer than henderson and also  tourists from the strip so everyone  agreed we presented to the mayor  she loved the idea passed it on to the  city they approved it  [Music]  this little community is ready we have  so many restaurants  with different offerings on on this  street and i think it's a great  opportunity for people  who have been cooped up in our house for  so long to get out and come downtown  and enjoy those restaurants and enjoy  our free parking here at seminole carson  and just enjoy the downtown community in  general  you